Jeff Passan of ESPN back here on the
show how are you Jeff Richard I'm well
yourself
this seems far more out of control than
the last time we chatted 10 days ago
Jeff what do you think what do you think
I've actually been around the Astros I
think this is my 11th day here and it's
gotten more out of control than I
expected honestly hi I didn't think that
this was going to be a story that went
away you know I was I was at the GM
meetings in in the Phoenix area back in
November and had heard that something
was coming in terms of the Astro science
ceiling stuff and then the Athletics
story dropped the next day and I
remember talking with executives from
the Red Sox with the Mets and with the
Houston Astros and I said to them guys
this is going to be the biggest story
since steroids and it might be bigger
and they were all skeptical and it has
exceeded my rather lofty expectations in
terms of the staying power and of the
inability of Major League Baseball to
have this go away
which it had hoped at this point would
have happened already and it ain't going
away well there Jeff it's not a lot of
layers left here to this story that
haven't even come close to being
uncovered no doubt and I'm not that I'm
not talking rich about like other teams
see less dealing times or anything like
that I'm talking you know the Red Sox
investigation Alex core is going to talk
Carlos Beltran's gonna talk players are
gonna throw it the Astro so what's gonna
happen with that what's the fallout
going to be you have a major league
baseball players association that is
bifurcated by 29 teams against the
Astros and the Astros just standing
there alone wearing it day after day
after day after day what does this do
and I'm not trying to make sympathetic
characters out of people who cheated at
sports but they're able to cheat at
sports and you know their their lives
are unbelievably changed because of this
decision that they made and the human
element of it I think becomes an
interesting story like this is just not
something that any time soon is going to
be going away Jeff Passan here on the
Rich Eisen show by the way your spot on
the
this is bigger than the steroid scandal
because there is no greater performance
enhancer than knowing what's coming
period end of story I've said it before
I'll set it again I probably even said
it to you if I'm a pitcher I'd rather be
facing some guy with a trapezoidal head
you know with acne coming off everywhere
because they're hopped up on 15
different horse medications than
somebody who knows exactly what's coming
I'd rather that that be the case all
that said the only way this seems to be
maybe to be put to bed or is if the
Commissioner changes in some way shape
or form his punishment and the question
is would the players who are so adamant
about getting their pound of flesh that
they're like mark cake is saying today
that everybody deserves a beating on the
Astros would they be willing to tell the
Union to back off and not sue the league
or file a grievance with the league if
the Commission removes the immunity that
he told all the players that told him
the truth they would have Jeff there is
absolutely zero chance rich that
something like that is going to happen
no matter how aggrieved the players from
the 29 other teams are this reminds me
of Alex Rodriguez when he was fighting
his long steroid suspension you know
went into the Commissioner's Office was
banging his head on the table and just
kind of acting innocence and the Union
you know I remember Michael Weiner
telling me this when he was alive and
Michael Weiner was before Tony Clark the
executive director and probably the
smartest person I've ever met and
Michael said to me and this is a tenant
that goes to all unions Union is only as
strong as its weakest member and right
now there are are weak members
throughout the houston astros
organization who are getting absolutely
crushed for what did what they did was
wrong what they did was bad and what
they did hopefully never will happen
again in the game of baseball but the
idea that the PA at this point and make
them sacrificial lambs to satiate the
bloodlust of their brethren I just
cannot fathom a scenario where that
happens you don't have a union if that
happens as simple as that so what's the
way out because
you point out no no cuz as you point out
you even said you know the red sock
stuff is coming beltron hasn't talked
korres and talked i mentioned at the top
of the show Jeff that there's probably a
member of the 2017 Astro is that maybe
in 2021 or 2022 we'll have a moment
where the conscience will just weigh on
them maybe they're gonna have a kid
right
a new kid they're gonna have a kid for
the first time and they're gonna look at
the child and say what what will they
read on the internet about their dad and
and they're gonna come out and say I was
the one who pounded on the trashcan
against you Darvish and this is the way
it went down you know like that's the
I'm just giving you an example so what's
the way I I think you know it's funny
rich cuz when I write critical columns
about people about situations about
institutions one of the things I try to
do is is to say okay I'm not just going
to criticize here I'm going to offer
solutions and I feel like I feel like
criticism without solutions is empty and
Hollow and just vacuous right I don't
have good solutions to this because
every solution seems to be contingent on
the idea that players are going to wear
it harder than they already are and I
just don't think legally that there is
any way for the institutions that are
involved here to make something like
that happen at the same time I wonder
what the public reaction rich would be
to something like stripping the title
from the Astros would they see it as
nothing more than a move to save face
especially considering Rob Manfred's
been on the record saying I don't want
to go down that path I feel like it's a
slippery slope if we take this away what
else are we going to take away I mean is
you know he was intimating the homerun
record like Barry Bonds clearly didn't
you know did the single-season record as
well as the all-time record while using
steroids and so if you strip away the
Astros title in 2017 does that mean you
have to go and do the same for bonds now
those are two separate instances and I
think you can argue that the what the
Astros did as you have is worse than
what Barry
or any other individual did but I the
the question of going out making a bold
indistinct move and then having the
public say that's still not enough
that's something that Rob Manfred simply
does not want to do and I don't blame
him for that like he's in a position
right now rich where he's got to do
everything right like this is a seminal
time for his Commissioner ship because
right now the tide is against baseball
from the fans from the players from the
whole continuum of people and Major
League Baseball needs to rescue itself
from that situation and I listen I wish
I had solutions I I don't know what the
best way out of this is Jeff Passan of
ESPN in the Honda inside a report well
let's game this out Jeff because I think
the commissioners a lonely man I mean
who are his allies in this one would say
Jim Crane who who steps on his
you-know-what every single time he opens
his mouth I'm serious or or or who the
players the players who are who he gave
immunity to who I'm wondering if there's
even dissension inside the locker room
of the Astros right I mean we're now
there's there's not okay I've been
around I've been around here not there's
not what about the pitchers what about
the pitchers I mean Verlander won the
damp the damn ALCS on his own arm in a
way you know that year I mean what's he
supposed to do after being acquired at
midnight of that trade deadline he's
supposed to walk in there and blow the
whistle on everybody I mean what so he's
not sitting there pissed off trying to
bite his tongue that's what I'm trying
to figure out here is that where where's
the way out where the Commissioner can
basically say all right
here's what we're gonna do whoever did I
found out bang bang to trashcan or use
this to hit a home run we're gonna sit
here for every single instance that I
found this out I'm putting it out there
I'll put it out there you may not be
punished but you're gonna be punished by
the information being in the hands of
fans and your teammates and your
comrades what about that Jeff okay so
let me ask you what what rich is that
consol because and it might solve
something but I see
like right now you know I listen I I
will never say that being in the belly
of the beast as I am now
is going to make me perfectly acute to
what's going on outside but I think I
have a fairly decent pulse of what the
public perception is right now yep and
it feels like the individuals already
are all getting crushed and that more
granular information about them is not
going to to make things any better I
think doing something like that purely
exists for for throwing meat to these
these rabid animals and listen I'm not
saying fans are fans or ball players
don't have reason to be angry they do
but I think a commissioner at a time
like this cannot do something just for
the sake of perception I think that is
the most dangerous thing no I thought
you can do I hear you but the whole
concept of the that that the players are
going off scot-free which is the
verbiage I've heard some players use
yeah that they're getting off scot-free
well nobody's sitting there and saying
well the reason why they got off
scot-free is because they told us about
this and the only reason why we know
about it so concretely is because we let
them get off scot free to tell us about
what happened that's getting lost in
everything and if I'm the commissioner
I'm saying how else would you want me to
handle this damn thing you know so let's
go let's go over a couple things with
average its points to make and I I
appreciate the fact that you're willing
to have a conversation like this because
we we get we get so caught up in who's
pissed off today and what they're saying
yes that that sometimes we miss the the
the really important details that are
going on here and and so you say the
players got off free right I can tell
you right now the players did not get
off free the players didn't get
suspended but they did not get off free
because their legacies their greatest
achievements their their integrity
everything is coming into question not
just from fans on the outside
who they you know they they're fans like
so players get used to fans booing them
saying bad things about them talking
about their moms whatever no this is
your peers and their peers are coming
after them in the same way that fans do
so the idea that they have not been
punished I you know I was talking with a
player earlier today rich who who said
to me very candidly I would rather
gotten suspended
I would rather gotten suspended and and
he said that because he feels like if
they got suspended that the the be just
the Just Desserts would have been given
and the players would not be coming out
times in a way that they are right time
sir faculty give me time served is
basically what you're saying a player
has told you in baseball let me say this
too and I think this is a this is a
really important point to make and one
that gets lost because we don't care
about nuance and don't care about law
and don't care about the the things that
go on behind closed doors and
smoke-filled rooms when a notice was
sent out in September of 2017 saying
that electronic sign ceiling can lead to
discipline for players hmm it was
incumbent on Geoff Luna and AJ Hinch the
general manager and manager of the
Houston Astros at the time to pass this
along to the players yes Rob Manfred
that's what he said in the letter this
was not done and when this is not done
there is a tentative labor law called
notice and what notice is is it requires
the employer to tell the employee when a
potential disciplinary issue has shifted
and what the potential discipline can be
when that does not happen rich the
ability to suspend somebody in this case
all practically falls apart
now you can argue that if your major
league baseball and you do go out and
suspend them anyway knowing you're going
to lose a grievance hearing that you are
putting it on the Major League Baseball
Players Association then to stand up for
these players who everyone knows cheated
and try and get them off and the thing
is they would have gotten off
suspensions would not have been held up
I talked with for labor lawyers about
the
I've talked with another one since I
wrote the story that it's both gone out
and suspended these players while true
these suspensions would never have been
held up because of the lack of notice
and that's a big part of this story I
think that was a big list of baseball
going the route that it did when it
decided not to suspend these players and
to give them immunity and that in part
in large part frankly is why we're in
the situation we're in right now where
everyone is so angry and and you know
what like I expect fans because this is
such a granular issue not to understand
or not to take the time you know we have
busy lives I totally understand that but
four players man like these are people
in your Union this could happen to you
too and so the idea that they haven't
gone and and taking the time to
understand why there were no students I
think makes them look hypocritical in
some ways well Jeff I love having this
conversation with you for two reasons
one because you can have it and and I
love the back-and-forth with you Jeff
and your tremendous at what you do and
two I want to talk about this more and
more to try and take away from the
botched tattoo of my daughter that I
have on my collarbone I don't want to
talk about it I'm trying to make sure
nobody pays attention to that Jeff jump
jumping the route and just yawning into
the end oh no I didn't mean what I said
about the first part you're great at
what you do thanks for the call Jeff
appreciate it thanks Jeff Passan for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on VR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app